hey guys this is Vadim with max sec and
today we're gonna be playing some games
on both the iPhone Tennis Max and the
one plus seven pro to see which one
offers a better gaming experience
now we're gonna play some asphalt 9 for
tonight in vainglory which supports 90
Hertz on the 1 + 7 Pro and we're also
gonna test out the battery life to see
which one drains more after an hour of
gameplay alright guys so here we are on
the 1 + 7 Pro you can see we're at a
hundred percent battery life and we've
got Bluetooth off everything's off and
we're up to 100% brightness to properly
test the better life and compared to the
iPhone Tennis max as you guys can see
we've got the gaming mode on just like
that hit OK and we're gonna go ahead and
get into asphalt 9 the first thing you
guys are gonna notice is this awesome
actually edge to edge display you don't
get any kind of teardrop you don't get a
notch like on the iPhone this seriously
looks amazing
so the game definitely doesn't feel as
smooth as the iPhone did when I played
it previously and you can definitely
tell that it's not 60fps it's like a
little bit guess stuttery compared to 60
nice everything looks really good the
colors are popping display looks amazing
I love this full screen you get all of
the screen real estate no knotch no
cutout nothing now let's switch to the
iPhone but before I jump into the game I
need to give a big shout-out to our
sponsor surrett wallpapers which is a
free app that has thousands of awesome
looking 4k wallpapers with more added
twice a week so swap out your boring
wallpaper right now download surrett
wallpapers for free using the link below
and here we are on the iPhone Tennis max
we're at a hundred percent battery life
we're gonna turn off the Bluetooth 100
percent brightness as well and let's go
ahead and jump into asphalt 9 so now
that I'm in game it seems like the
display is a little bit brighter so I'm
gonna adjust my camera make it a tiny
bit darker got the display settings in
here we actually have an option for 60
fps and we have that enabled so now you
can really tell that the notch is here
after coming from the
+7 Pro alright let's do this pull off a
nice drift I did not see that coming
so far the 60fps is definitely
noticeable it's seriously seriously
smooth and I'm not getting any drop
frames nothing everything looks
absolutely amazing so now we're gonna
open vainglory this is the ninety Hertz
game now at this point we're gonna go
and make sure that we're at ninety Hertz
there we go we're still at ninety Hertz
okay so so far the display feels super
smooth feels incredibly smooth I think
you'll have to look really close to
notice it's 90 FPS but so far it feels
incredibly smooth this display looks
awesome I love not having to deal with
any kind of not cut out nothing you
don't get any of that awesome
[Music]
I'm running you got me
[Music]
yeah
yes so I'm loving the speakers you
finally get stereo speakers and they
actually work really well you can hear
different sounds from both sides well we
definitely lost this match but I can
definitely say it was a blast it runs
perfectly smooth on this phone it feels
incredibly smooth and Alice plebian
glory on the iPhone we're running get
him this now on the iPhone it definitely
feels pretty smooth but it kind of
notice it's not as good I did do it I'm
so far behind now no I got away having
no issues at all
with lag or anything like that no
dropped frames nothing it's perfect oh
let's go let's go let's go let's go get
him get him get him yes
we're get them yes we got yes
whoa we did it
we have won the game what a comeback as
you guys can see the gameplay was
totally amazing on this phone we did
better than last time
I think it's a little bit worse because
it's not 90 °f PS at 60 still feels
great no dropped frames nothing feels
perfectly fine alright guys here we are
in fortnight on the 1 + 7 Pro is going
to the graphics settings and you can see
that you're limited to 30 fps
no matter which quality you choose so
we're just gonna do epic 30fps which
really sucks because this display
refresh rates 90 so here we are and it's
definitely 30 fps
not 60 but the graphics quality looks
absolutely insane it looks incredible
and so far no dropped frames not
noticing any so far this also looks
amazing graphics quality is insane
everything's running incredibly well so
far the screen looks amazing everything
looks great very bright colourful
well if he's a little bit glitchy there
so I am getting some drop frames here
and there Oh actually got somebody ha
that was afk
but whatever ah anyways I've been
playing for almost an hour and this
phone really hasn't been heating up that
much like I've noticed a bunch of other
phones heating up more than this guy so
it's been exactly an hour so let's go
ahead and check our battery life as you
can see it's been exactly an hour we are
at 82% battery life actually for a full
hour at a hundred percent brightness
that's actually not that bad and now on
the iPhone tennis max is going to the
graphics settings you can see 60 FPS at
high graphics quality but if we go to
epic we do not have the choice of 60 FPS
on epics so we're just going to do high
60 fps alright in game you can
definitely tell it's 60 FPS what do I do
here what would you guys see that the
brightness drops by itself
oh just off man that auto-aim suck so
bad
interestingly I'm now starting to feel
the back of the phone heat up right in
this area I think that's where the
processor is at and it's heating up
quite a bit oh I got one guy hey John
wick
this is Chadwick John wicks doing
backflips everything still feels very
smooth even though it's warmed up I'd
rather have it dim then lose some
graphics performance and have it be all
choppy and and laggy and all that so got
him oh you got a snipe me all right guys
so it's been exactly an hour on the
iPhone tennis max as you can see let's
check the battery life Wow
75% so it's actually quite a bit worse
than the 1 plus 7 Pro and that's with
the display dimming in fortnight so
after playing games on both of these
phones for one hour here are my
conclusions first off the all screen
display on the oneplus 7 pro was awesome
you don't have to deal with any of these
notches and it's awesome that this phone
did not heat up as much as they act on
tennis max did which the issue of this
is after a heats up to a certain point
the display dims automatically by itself
you can't do anything about it and
that's where we keeping this room for
overheating now obviously it was playing
fortnight at 60fps instead of 30 so it's
more graphically demanding and that may
be why but the downside is that we were
left with 75 percent battery life
instead of 82 with the dimming whereas
this phone did not dim at all for the
entire hour so I'm actually really
impressed with the battery life on this
phone for gaming so an asphalt 9 the
iPhone 10's max is the clear winner it
runs at 60fps this is limited to 30 and
didn't feel that smooth much better
experience on the iPhone 10's max and
for vainglory both phones did extremely
well but this was running at 90 fps
instead of 60 it was kind of hard to
tell the difference you probably could
if you
really really tried but it ran very well
on both phones so you guys let me know
which phone you think did better in the
comment section below thanks for
watching make sure to hit that button
above to subscribe and if you haven't
seen those videos right there definitely
check them out thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]